[Musique]
et pour clôturer ce journal mélanie
pocketnow a rejoint en plateau bonsoir
ça votre coup de coeur de la semaine
mélanie c'est un spectacle magique et
poétique et oui c'est le fabuleux voyage
de la fée mélodies dans ce spectacle a
été pensé en 2011 notamment par
stéphanie marino mélodie est donc une
fée à qui il arrive une mésaventure elle
perd une de ses notes le la à cause d'un
coup de vent
le problème c'est que cela est une autre
très importante c'est celle qui permet
notamment aux instruments de s'accorder
j'imagine que melody va essayer de
retrouver cela oui mais pas tout seul
grégory la fée va faire appel au public
les enfants vont être tour à tour l'eau
le vent le soleil les plus grands les
parents et les grands parents ne sont
pas en reste ce fabuleux voyage est
truffé de références comme mary poppins
et noir désir mais pas qu il ya plein
d'univers différents qui m'ont inspiré
pour l'écriture des textes il ya plein
de textes eux-mêmes qui m'ont inspiré
comme par exemple le petit prince aussi
et l'envi en fait c'est venu au départ
de raconter une histoire autour de la
musique pour les petits pour les initier
un peu à ce qu'est la musique avec un
univers très féerique très poétique
une question importante qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait votre coup de coeur
sa simplicité alors pas d'un sens
péjoratif bien sûr mélodies nous
entraîne dans un monde poétique et
magique poétique car on découvre tous
les éléments qui composent la terre le
ciel la mer et la terre bien sûr et
c'est aussi magique parce que c'était
faris était fanny marino joue avec les
ombres chinoises elles jouaient ce qui
introduit par fois et comme on n'est pas
à l'abri d'un autre coup de vent le
fabuleux voyage est à découvrir à la
royale factory de versailles jusqu'à
vendredi
merci mélanie ce spectacle et bien
d'autres choses encore à retrouver dans
l'émission le 7-8 culture présentée dans
un instant dans quelques instants par
vous